the West African Regional block Echo is
an institution in crisis three of its 15
member states want out and there is a
political crisis in Sagal after
president maal delayed the presidential
elections due in February if there has
been any
time for Echo to stay
together this is the
time
if we have been ever
challenged this is actually the time we
have been most
challenged Nigeria which chairs the
regional group is asking members to
continue dialogue and warning about the
consequences of failure the exit from
eoas would be much worse than the
sanctions in terms of the hardship that
it would put it would Place uh the CI
cens of these three countries so we
don't wish it upon them we don't want to
see that official CC sagal's recent
political crisis as an unnecessary
destruction its foreign minister
attended Thursday's meeting insisting
the situation there is not
critical the president has initiated a
dialogue the situation doesn't require
external intervention from Echo Au or
other bodies while the echo's ability to
intervene in Sagal is limited it's
focusing on the Rebellion by Burkina
Faso Mali and ner the three Sahel region
countries were already suspended from
the Block after recent calls binaso Mali
and N said the organization has derailed
and is pondering to the wishes of
foreign powers so they're leaving but EO
says its rules require one year's notice
before membership is ended but the three
countries all under military rule say
they're leaving anyway the United
Nations warns that the unfolding
political CR crisis threatens the entire
region should these countries
definitively withdraw from eoas this has
a potential to further exacerbate the
challenges that these three countries
and the sub region are facing notably in
the socio economic and security Fields
echos has options before it to Blink and
submit to the wishes of the rebelling
countries or continue its blockade and
sanctions either way political analy say
it could be a long time before the
organization recovers from this current
crisis Ahmed rris Al jazer
Abuja make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer